[Musique]
ils ont 9 10 13 16 ou encore 17 ans ils
sont l'avenir des acadiens à l'île du
prince édouard et ses plus jeunes assume
fièrement cette forte responsabilité
continue et mathieu ateliers allez la
france a pas ma famille alors qu'on dise
tout comme on n'y a que du bonheur mais
c'est pas juste là savoir la langue mais
c'est aussi et pour en arriver là
parents grands parents s'activent au
quotidien pour transmettre les valeurs
acadienne aux plus jeunes un véritable
défi pour ces familles
c'est un défi ça prend un effort c'est
pas toujours facile mais ça prend un
effort bio des opportunités de le faire
l'école est très important le conseil le
conseil des verts est très important
mais inculquer la fierté de qui on est
la fierté de de chanter une autre
notre culture notre journée tous les
joueurs de talent français à la maison
avec nos enfants
et cela fonctionne
conscients des enjeux et de l'importance
de conserver les racines acadiennes et
lé français les plus jeunes partagent
eux aussi ses valeurs ainsi que la
langue autour d'eux c'est quelque chose
d'important
juste par les enfants s'ils pensent que
c'est assez mais c'est pas toujours
assez il faut ouvrir au prince est
presque à la fin c'est parce que ces
langages kahn qui était comme celle du
wec en même temps les hôtesses et c'est
beau de voir les comme une école ici un
faux frère
justement les écoles sont la clé de
cette transmission d'un bout à l'autre
de la province
les centres scolaires et communautaires
jouent un rôle primordial dans la
conservation et dans le développement du
français
en fait beaucoup d'activités
intergénérations avec les grands-parents
la communauté âgées pour avoir les
jeunes était de voir ce qui se passe
notre école pierre chiasson aussi faux
que fait beaucoup d'activités la
communauté avec les aînés pour tracer
cette richesse là de la langue française
cette réussite dépasse aujourd'hui le
cadre des écoles les municipalités ou
encore les entreprises de la province
réclame c'est acadien francophone gdsa
mon école qui ont créé des emplois d'été
parce qu'ils y sont ils les passent
toujours à des points clés pour
promouvoir la langue puis les jeunes ils
sont en train de développer cette fierté
là et si le chemin de la transmission
des valeurs s'annonce enfin elle est
néanmoins en bonne voie
chanter des chansons de lennie gallant
un français fait que c'est déjà à 7 ans
je vois qu'elle quel point cette fierté
puis c'est vraiment beau à avoir des
faux sa mère en larmes aux yeux le
pouvoir ça parce que c'est très spécial
actuellement
ici je n'allais cachera du canada
charlottetown